Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
As animation movies and computer game graphics
become more and more realistic, they draw
us more and more into their own worlds.
However, when we see cars, mugs, minerals
and paintings, and similar materials, we often
feel that something is not right there, and
the illusion quickly crumbles.
This is such a peculiar collection of materials...so
what is the common denominator between them?
Normally, to create these beautiful images,
we use programs that create millions and millions
of rays of light and simulate how they bounce
off of the objects within the scene.
However, most of these programs bounce these
rays off of the surface of these objects,
where in reality, there are many sophisticated
multi-layered materials with all kinds of
coatings and varnishes.
Such a simple surface model is not adequate
to model these multiple layers.
This new technique is able to simulate not
only these surface interactions, but how light
is scattered, transferred and absorbed within
these layers, enabling us to create even more
beautiful images with more sophisticated materials.
We can envision new material models with any
number of layers and it will be able to handle
it.
However, I left the best part for last.
What is even cooler is that it takes advantage
of the regularity of the data and builds a
statistical model that approximates what typically
happens with our light rays within these layers.
What this results in is a real-time technique
that still remains accurate.
This is not normal.
This used to take hours!
This is insanity!
And the whole paper was written by only one
author, Laurent Belcour and was accepted to
the most prestigious research venue in computer
graphics.
So huge congrats to Laurent for accomplishing
this.
If you would like to learn more about light
transport, I am holding an Master-level course
on it at the Technical University of Vienna.
This course used to take place behind closed
doors, but I feel that the teachings shouldn't
only be available for the 20-30 people who
can afford a University education, but they
should be available for everyone.
So, we recorded the entirety of the course
and it is now available for everyone, free
of charge.
If you are interested, have a look at the
video description to watch them.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!